abone ol
[Müzik]
Herkese
merhaba arkadaşlar
Bir kalp hekimi olarak yıllarca ölümün
ve yaşamın en yakın kıyısında yer alan
insanlarla uğraştım bugün sizlere
onlarla olan bazı gelişmeleri mi
hikayelerini anlatmak istiyorum
bildiğiniz gibi insan kalbi canlılığını
hissettiren en önemli iç organımız bir
kas pompası ve bu kas pompası
bir dakikada yetmiş kere atıyor ama bir
günde 3 bin ton kanı 3 ton kanı periferi
atıyor ve 80 yaşında bir insana
geldiğimizde 3 milyar kere çalışan bir
kas pompası çok güçlü bir pompa
yorgunluğa dirençli bir pompa ama
hastalandığı zaman
Yok
maalesef son evreye kalp yetersizliğine
geldiği zaman insanlar çok kısa sürede
hayatlarını kaybediyorlar aylar haftalar
bazen günler içerisinde hayatlarını
kaybediyorlar bu Vücudumuzdaki en ağır
kanser türü pankreas hızlı ölüme götüren
Pankreas kanseri kadar güçlü bir şekilde
hastanın hayatına son veriyorlar o
noktada yani kalp yetersizliğinin son
evresinde elimizdeki tane silah var
Hastanın daha uzun yaşaması yeniden
hayata doğru bağlanması için biri kalp
nakli kalp nakli çok bilinen bir yöntem
1960'lardan beri Doktor Christian bana
artı Amerika'dan oluşan ve İstan Ford
grubu tarafından geliştirilen herşeyle
bildiğimiz bir teknik çok da etkili bir
yöntem Türkiye'de bu işi
diyap an benim çok değerli hocam Kemal
Bayazıt kendisiyle on yıl çalıştım ve o
zaten da ikimize bu ateşi
kalp nakli ile insanları yaşatma onlara
yeniden hayat imkanı sunabilme imkanı
bize içimize yüreğimize yakan kişidir
onu rahmetle anıyorum Türkiye'de bugün
kalp ameliyatları yapılıyorsa yüzde
ellisi onun tedrisatından ekolünden
geçmiş cerrahlardan oluşmaktadır O
yüzden Kemal Hoca emekli olsa da hep
bizim arkamızda oldu bir 2009 yılında
İstanbul'da ilk dert nakli yaptığım
zaman hasta mı görmeye 75 yaşındaydı
emekli olmuştur ve beni ve hasta mı
Tebrik etmeye gelmişti Eh Daha sonra ben
onun hayatını bir kitap haline getirdim
Çünkü tüm Tıp öğrencileri ve hatta
mühendislerin o kitabı okumasını çok
ağrı elde etmek için orada çok önemli
hayat hikayeleri ve tedavi yöntemlerini
nasıl hangi cesaretle girdiğini
anlatıyordu
Evet kalp naklinde hasta bir kalbi
çıkarıyorsunuz yine bir kalp
implantı ediyorsunuz ama bu en zor
işlerinden bir tanesidir
organizasyonu çok yüksek yapmalısınız 50
kişi görev alır Trabzon'da kalp var
gideceksiniz alacaksınız kalbi
çıkaracaksınız ambulansa Bileceksiniz
havalimanına geleceksiniz uçağa
Bileceksiniz İstanbul'a geleceksiniz
ambulansla tekrar sana geleceksiniz
kalbi takacaksınız en az bir buçuk saat
toplamda bu işi 4 saatte bitireceksiniz
yani toplamda Maximum altı saati
geçtiniz o kalpten Hayır gelmiyor
çalışmıyor bu büyük bir organizasyon Ama
bu organizasyonu sonu çok yüz güldürücü
işte bakın Altı ay sonra bu genç
delikanlı o yataktan kalkamıyor Doo 6 ay
sonra daha taşa tırmanıyor Spor
yapabiliyor bu şekilde insanlara 8.
yılında 11 yılında 12 yılında 23.
yılında kalp nakli ile yaşama imkanı
verebiliyorsunuz yeniden doğuş imkanı
verebiliyorsunuz Dolayısıyla kalp nakli
Çok etkili bir tedavi yöntemi Ama bu
maalesef maalesef çok az sayıda organ
var Herkese yetmiyor Örneğin on kişiden
ancak bir tanesini O da büyük şansla
bulabiliyor Peki dokuz kişi ne oluyor
onlar hayatlarını kaybediyorlar bir şey
bulamadım bir tedavi yöntemi bulamadan
Bu hafta da çok şanslı bunu önce kalp
nakli yaptık bu genç delikanlıya
ardından iki sene sonunda böbrek nakli
yaptık hem kalbi değiştiren böbreği
değişti Türkiye'de yaşayan nadir
insanlardan bir tanesi o yüzden
organlarda çok Sinbo standart ama organ
bulabilirsiniz bugün tüm dünyada 150 bin
tane kalp nakli yapılmış 1968 yılından
beri Ama bu Bu hastalar Milyonlar
Türkiye'de bugün kalp nakli bekleyen
listelenmiş mm ama listelenmemiş on bine
yakın insan var peki kaç kalp nakli
yapıyoruz yılda 27 30 tane yüzü geçmiyor
E ne oluyor gibi binlerce insan
hayatlarını kaybediyor İşte bu durumda
Bu bir çare lazım bu çare nedir bu çare
hiç kuşku yok ki
yapay kalp sistemi şimdi sizi 1966'da
götürmek istiyorum 1966 yılında Dr
Michael direkt İHH Üstün da belli kaljo
cm'e dışında bir kalp ameliyatı yapıyor
hasta Meksikalı bir kadın kalp kapakları
bozulmuş ameliyat ediyor iki kalp
kapağını değiştiriyor ama kaç çalışmıyor
saatler geçiyor ilaç tedavileri
yapıyorlar şunu yapıyorlar bunu
yapıyorlar bakın o ameliyathaneden bir
fotoğrafı o ameliyattan bir kesit
insanların yüzündeki endişeyi
tedirginliği görüyor musunuz nedir bu
Ben biraz sonra karar verilecek hasta
Morgan indirilecek başka türlü yok
çalışmı 1966 İşte o noktada Dr Michael
bekliyor ki laboratuvarda köpekler
üzerinde denediğimiz makineyi getirin
eve götürüyorlar makinayı kocaman bir
şey hastanın göğsün içinde kalbin
içinden kan ağlıyor dolaşıma pompalıyor
çok basit prototip ama işe yarıyor
hastanın göğsü kapatılıyor yoğun bakıma
çıkıyor on gün bu şekilde yaşıyor gözünü
açıyor uyanıyor üç gün sonra
az önce bir makine bir bakıyorlar ki
ondan sonra kart güzelmiş Çünkü
çalışıyordu boş çalışıyordu makine o
görev üstlenmişti ardından makine
çıkarıyorlar ve bu kadın 22 yıl Mexico
City bir trafik kazasında ölene kadar
hayatını sürdürür kalp hastalığından
ölüm var işte bu bir başlangıçtır Dünya
tıbbında büyük bir başlangıçtır ve bu
kadar büyük makinayı acaba göğsün
içerisine alabilir miyiz alamayız o
zaman bakış açımızı değiştirmemiz
gerekiyor mühendis gözüyle değil daha
kalbi taklit eden bir pompa yapmak
yerine başka bir mentalite düşünmemiz
lazım o da nedir kanı içine almayacak
sadece conflow ve kırdık yapacak bir
Türbülans motor bunu nerede
kullanıyorlar nasa'daki uzay
mekiklerinin enjeksiyon pompalarında
günün birinde devlet sus isimli bir
nasıl baş mühendisi kalp nakli olunca Dr
bu ile yolu kesişiyor oturuyorlar 80
yılların ortasında bu projeyi
düşünüyorlar ve 90'lı yılların sonuna
doğru da gerçekleştiriyorlar işte ben o
noktada amerikadaydım küstün daydım
Doktor dileğini merkezinde yedim bunu
gözlemleme imkanı gördüm ve akabinde de
bu sistemi acaba Türkiye getirebilir
miyiz in peşine düştüm vermediler
getiremezsin dediler daha Türkiye
portreyi de yok dediler ne yapabiliriz
ne edebiliriz ama takipte kaldık Takipte
kal Bakın bu sistem gerçekten son derece
etkili bir minyatür bir parmak boyutunda
kalbin içine koyduğunuz zaman dakikada
10 litre yakın kan pompalıyor hastanın
kalp yeter sizin ortadan kaldırıyorsunuz
tek bir şey şuradan bir kablo çıkıyor
hastanın üzerinde bir batarya sistemi
var Bu da zaten yakın bir gelecekte
ortadan kalkıp tam bir wireless hale
getirilmekte
işte Daha önce kontrol ünitesi kocaman
da şimdi neredeyse hasta O yanında
taşıdığı küçük bir çanta tarzına büründü
yakın gelecekte dediğim gibi Tamam ne
var diye soracak küçük yelek giyecek
hasta kablosuz olarak enerji transferi
ile sistem çalışır hale getirecek Bu
sistem çok yüksek enerji gerektiriyor üç
aylık enerjisini şöyle düşünebilirsiniz
100 bin kilometre yapan bir araba motoru
üç ayda Bu üçü kullanacak bu sistem 2-3
yıl on yıl on beş yıl 20 yıl da
kullananlar var milyon kilometre yapmış
bir motordan bahsediyoruz O yüzden
bunlar çok ciddi bir hendislik
dizaynları gerektiren on binde bir
yapıyor bir santimetre içerisinde ama
eritrosit dediğimiz alyuvarların tahrip
etmiyor son derece etkili sistemleri
işte bir avucunuzun içine sığabilecek
boyutta küçücük sistemler Dr Michael de
ki o noktada devreye girdi ve dedi ki
Türkiye'ye madem sen bu işi bu kadar çok
peşindesin Ben de atalarım Lübnan'da
yaşamış Osmanlı da aynı altında yaşamış
insanlardı ben severim Türkleri Çalışkan
dürüst insanlardır mm bir yılında Bu
sistemin Türkiye'de kullanılmasına izin
veriyorum çünkü 6 ülke belirlemişler de
Avrupa'da Almanya Fransa İngiltere
İtalya İsviçre Avusturya 7 ülke olarak
bize bunu verdiler Çünkü eski onay
verdikten sonra hemen bunu
ticarileştirme imkanı olmuyor en az iki
sene sonra gelecek ve mm yılında biz bu
sistemi Türkiye'ye getirdik bu insana
taktık yataktan çıkamayan yoğun bakımda
iki üç defa kalbi durmuş makinalara
bağlanmış bu insana taktık ve bu insan
üç ay sonra egzersiz yapabilecek hale
geldi 6 ay sonra kalp nakli yaptık İki
sene sonra burada altı sene sonra ve şu
anda Urfa'da 19 yılında kalp nakli
hayatını sürdürüp işte size bir yeniden
doğurur ölümün kıyısından bu makinayla
hayata yeniden getirir Türkiye'de bu ilk
olayı Tabii ki yay O çok asla var bu
açıdan ne yapabiliriz ne yapabiliriz
İşte bu 2006 İstanbul'da ilk yapay kalbi
2006 yılında yeter Üniversitesi'nde
kullanmıştık bunu yaygınlaştırma yolu
Çünkü bu işler çok pahalı 100 bin dolar
bir Makina 100 bin doları herkes verecek
hemen anında çıkacak nerede çok az çok
rahat çok az insan Dolayısıyla bu
yaygınlaşmamış lazım toplu toplumda bir
sosyal güvenlik kurumunun ödemesiyle
yaygınlaştırma mız lazım onun için
Dernek kurdum yapıyor anlar Derneği'ni
kurdu mi üç tane büyük kongre yaptık
sonunda Avrupa Amerikan Japon dernekleri
bizi tanıdı ve Davet ettiler Biz de
onları İstanbul'a davet etti ki
İstanbul'da 2012 yılında Dünya yapay
kalp kongresi yapıldı ve bu dünya
yaparken kongresinde Türkiye'deki sosyal
güvenlik yetkilileri de gördüler bu işin
önemini anladılar ve SGK nın ödemesine
girdi ve ondan sonra gördüğünüz gibi
Türkiye'de uygulamalar başladı Bu bir
şeyler yapmayacak bir şeyler olmuyor
Arkadaşlar birşeyleri bu şey etmemiz
gerekiyor ama inandığınız yolda bu
sistemlerle insan yaşatılıyorsa Bu
sistemler insanların hizmetinde olmalı
bu Gaye ile hareket ettik ve bu yolda
Türkiye'de bir adım attık ve çok şükür
Bugün iki bine yakın insan Belki de bu
sayede yaşıyor bakın hava ambulansıyla
getirmiş kalp yeter sizin son evresinde
belki günleri var bu adamın Ama bu
cihazı taktık ardından 20 gün sonra
evine gönderiyoruz yine bir kadın
yataktan çıkamıyor yoğun bakımdan
çıkamıyor saatleri var Belki de ama daha
sonra 20 gün sonra evinde işlerini
yapabilecek bir ay sonra dışarıda
gezebilecek hale gelebiliyor ekmo bugün
koyup nedeniyle çok iyi biliyorsunuz ek
moda Son Nokta akciğerler mahvolmuş yok
olmuş işte bir kadın ek moda kalp
yetersizliği nedeniyle Bu da saatleri
var belki birkaç gün ama bir makine
takıyorsunuz ardından 20 gün sonra bu
konuda evine doğru gidebiliyor bunları
nasıl yapıyorsunuz bu sistemlerle kalp
nakli sırası gelmiş istemiyor kalp
naklini kalbin gayeti bu makine bana çok
iyi geliyor diyor işte 8 yılında dokuz
yılında On yılında insanlarımız var
Dolayısıyla bu sistemleri
yaygınlaştırmak için çok uğraştık ama
yaygınlaştırılır kende karşımıza tabi
Finans diye bir şey çıktı Bunlar çok
pahalı sistemler dediğim gibi bir Sosyal
Güvenlik Kurumu da bunları Kabul etmekte
çok zorlanıyor O nedenle Ne yapalım Ne
yapalım bunu Türkiye'de işte bakın
burada örnekler görüyorsunuz birçok
Hayat birçok yeniden doğuş bunlar yani
saatler günler haftalar İçerisinde
hayatını kaybedecek insanları yeniden
Yıllar yılı yaşayabilir hale getirmek bu
sistemleri acaba
Türkiye'de Yapabilir miyiz bu sefer de
onun peşine düştük son bir örnek
veriyorum hasta örneği Bu da dünyanın
21. hasta ne biçim veriyorum burada çok
ağırdı kalp hastalığı vardı kalbi
çıkarıp yerine Total makine taktık işte
hastanın kalbi çok az çalışıyor yerine
taktığımız Makina Total artık işi var
Bilginiz olsun Türkiye'deki 30 tane
yapılmıştır Bu üçüncü hastadır benim
yaptığım tek yaşayan ilk yaşayan
hastadır O yüzden önemi var ve bu dünya
liepke basın şeyinde de yer aldı
Amerika'dan onay sonra biz Türkiye'de bu
ameliyatı gerçekleştirdik ve başarılı
bir şekilde oldu hastamıza biraz ekstrem
bir örnekte sporu böyle seviyordu
Neticede dünyada bu işin babasından
Doktor fraser da Türkiye'ye geldi bizi
bu ameliyatı yaptığımız için de tebrik
etti ve geliştirdik bu sistemi tabi
arkamızda büyük bir ekip var bir
kardiyoloji ekibi var bu başarıları
onlarla birlikte yapıyoruz tek başına
diyemem Sonuçta bu iş 100.000 dolarlık
bir sistem s Bunu hiçbir Sosyal Güvenlik
Kurumu ile Evet desteklemez
ya bizimde Bunun maliyeti sürecek yerli
ve özel şeyler yapmamız lazım
mentalitesi ile yola çıktığımızda
2006 yılında Bedrettin Dalan beyefendi
Yeditepe Üniversitesi'nin kurucusu beni
destekledi dedi ki bunu bir proje lendir
Biz de bu işi Türkiye'de yapalım ve
mühendisi arkadaşlarla bir araya gelerek
Koç Üniversitesi Yeditepe Üniversitesi
makine bölümleri hep beraber kafa kafaya
vererek bir proje oluşturduk TÜBİTAK
destekledi ve İstanbul Ben Türk'ü asisti
varsa adını verdiğimiz İstanbul yapay
kalbi 7.ay hard olarak da ifade
ettiğimiz sistemi oluşturduk ve bu gün
bu sistem üretildi yapıldı tür titanyum
200 gram
dakikada 8 litre kan pompalayan biliyor
Tabi bunu denemeleri yapıldığı
çalışmaları yapıldı ve son olarakta
en son 90 kilogramlık büyük
ve onlara implant etik hayvan
çalışmaları yapıp sonra insana geçmek
gerekiyor ve orada da başarılı neticeler
aldık ama araya pandemi girdi tam son
denemeleri yaparken fan demirleri
laboratuvar larımızı kapandı Şimdi ümit
ediyorum mm 22'nin ortalarından sonra bu
son çalışmalarımızda yapacağız ve
ardından bu sistemi insanlığın hizmetine
ve tüm Öncelikle Türk insanının
hizmetine ve sonra da tüm insanlığa
hizmeti vermek istiyor sevgili
arkadaşlar kalp yetersizliği dünyada
30-40 milyon İnsanı etkileyen bir iş
Türkiye'de 3 ila 5 milyon kalp
yetersizliği hasta var ama bunların Son
evresine geldiği zaman bir kanser gibi
düşündüğünüzde 4. evreye Geldiği Zaman
Ki Bu hastalar Türkiye'de 10000
civarında
saatler günler haftalar var çoğu yoğun
bakıma giriyor bir daha çıkmıyor Biz
bunları biliyor Görüyoruz işte bu
insanlara bir kısmına önemli bir kısmına
bu yöntemlerle imkanı bu Ama bu bir
teknoloji bunu devamlı gelişen bir
teknoloji aynı telefon teknolojisi gibi
buna bunun arkasında konuşmamız lazım
mühendisi arkadaşlarla kafa kafaya verip
bu gelişmeleri sürdürmemiz lazım tabii
ki biyomekanik bir çözüm bu insan biraz
ters gelebilir kalbin içinde bir Makina
şu anki gerçek bu Önümüzdeki on yıl 20
yıl da böyle geçecek ha Ne zaman ki
sizlere kim arkadaşlarım araştırmacılar
Mühendisler bir araya gelip Kök hücreyi
veya Birgen tedavisini veya bir doku
mühendisliğini gerçek anlamda
uygulanabilir hale getirdiğiniz zaman o
zaman bu tedavide Tabii ki miyadını
doldurmuş olacak ama şu anda ve yakın
gelecekte Bundan başka kalp
yetersizliğinde yeniden doğuşu ribonu
sağlayacak başka bir metod yok
arkadaşlar ve Bu çalışmalar yümit
ediyorum bir tarafta Mühendisler bir
tarafta Tıp doktorları kafa kafaya
vererek Önümüzdeki yılları şey hep bir
bu evlendireceğiz Ben diyorum ki ribon
bir yerde remodelling bir yeniden
şekillenmektedir O yüzden herkes yeniden
şekillenmeye düşünsün ve ona göre
hayatını ve çalışma hayatını dizaynı
etsin eğer ribonu istiyorsan hepinize
sevgiler saygılar sunuyorum
[Alkış]